well that's it you all have your degrees
you could leave now but I know you're
too polite to do that because you want
to hear my 45 minutes speech before you
go out into the world actually I've
decided to depart from my speech that I
worked on so hard for the last several
days because actually after hearing
errands speech how could I possibly
follow that or top it and I won't show
you what I wearing under my all right so
now he's cracking jokes behind Thank You
Erin you're right I am rethinking that
imitation that actually I was going to
talk about three people erin was the
first one nuff said nothing else I have
to say the second was Randy Pausch and I
was just going to point out to you that
one of the great metaphors he left us
with was the idea of prick walls what
randy said was prick walls were not put
up to stop you they were put up to test
how much you wanted something and he in
particular said they'd probably stop a
lot of people but a Carnegie Mellon we
see them simply as an enhanced challenge
that was Randy but of course Randy meant
much more than that to us you will
remember the undergraduates i should say
the new bachelor's recipients that Randy
died in the summer after your freshman
year so you were still touched by Randy
you still had them had them in your life
in your lives for a little bit Erin in
Randy I could stop there that's pretty
good role models for you think about
people who are also Carnegie Mellon
alumni now just the way you are there's
a third person I want to talk about but
this will take a little bit longer to
provide
the context here at Carnegie Mellon we
emphasize in our curricular in our
curricula deep content knowledge
problem-solving ability awareness of the
world's needs self-sufficiency and
determine motivation in each of these
each of these you could see his seeds
and what Aaron told you about in his own
experience and if you remember Randy's
lakhs last lecture and the wisdom he
imparted this should sound familiar as
well these elements though also
represents the recipe for an
entrepreneur Carnegie Mellon has been
doing entrepreneurship teaching and
research since at least the 1970s but
it's really just the last few years that
this has begun to enter the mainstream
of student dreams and career plans here
starting a business is now a widely
shared ambition both among students and
young faculty and that's great news for
America and for the world because it's
new companies that are the major
generators of new jobs and a stronger
economy they're also the generator of
ideas that are the basis for improved
lives and our work they're a very
important part of the economy and in the
lives we lead carnegie mellon's done a
great deal of recent years to improve
the campus and pittsburgh climate for
company creation under the leadership of
vice president richard mccullough who's
a company founder himself we've been
building and enriching what brick calls
the innovation ecosystem adding to the
long-standing and internationally
recognized on Jones center in the tempur
school which gives students vital skills
for starting companies we now have
project Olympus in the School of
Computer Science created and led by
professor Lenore Blum in programs and
courses in innovation
in cit we have a revamped technology
transfer office and improved technology
transfer policy which has become a model
for other universities across the
country in fact Carnegie Mellon now
ranks second in the country in terms of
the number of startup companies we
create each year per dollar of sponsor
research most of you may be thinking
well that's nice but what does it have
to do with me indeed that's why I
brought up the topic while we've been
building the innovation ecosystem we've
not yet reached out in a concerted way
to the student body or our alumni nor I
have to admit is Carnegie Mellon
necessarily the first place you think of
when you want to go someplace to learn
to be an entrepreneur even if the
training in fact that you get here
prepares you to be one very well indeed
well today we're going to change that
jonathan kaplan was sitting where you
are now 21 years ago about to receive
his degree in a self-defined major that
included business administration
engineering and design he was already an
entrepreneur as a student Jonathan's
most recent venture was the company that
created and sold the flip video camera
one of the most successful products of
all time Jonathan Jonathan became
wealthy from the success of the flip but
he's not only an entrepreneur he and his
wife Marcy Glazer like you care deeply
about the world around them and they're
using their wealth to make a difference
in the world this would be admirable in
any person but it's remarkable to me for
someone as young as Jonathan and Marcy
Jonathan cares about this university and
he's joining with us today to help spark
entrepreneurship here to make Carnegie
Mellon the destination for entrepreneurs
I'm pleased to announce today that
Jonathan and Marci have made a very
generous donation to create what we will
call the open field entrepreneurs fund
it will be used to invest in start-up
companies of recent CMU graduates that
would be you and when you're successful
like Jonathan we expect you to
contribute back to the fund to replenish
it to build the fund back up so we can
keep supporting future alumni of course
if you hit it really big we'll be happy
to talk to you about other ways you can
leave your legacy at Carnegie Mellon
University well not only was Jonathan
sitting here 21 years ago but he's
actually sitting here today as well I'd
like him to rise now he's somewhere way
back there Jonathan oh he's waving keep
two hands Jonathan
our thanks to you Jonathan and the Marcy
for creating this fun we really do think
this will be an important catalysts not
just in the individual companies that
some of you will create and we hope
you'll take advantage of the fund by the
way go to the CMU website / open field
and it's already up you'll get the
information we hope you'll take
advantage of it but we hope and
johnathan hopes and we believe it will
make a mark for Carnegie Mellon and say
to the world if you want to be an
entrepreneur this is the place to come
we know that to be true but now the
world will know it as well aron ralston
randy pausch and jonathan kaplan it's
quite a group and you're now one of them
which is to say you're an alumnus or
alumna of Carnegie Mellon University
it's a source of pride but it also means
you have the tools experience in habits
of mind to be successful you know the
meaning and value of hard work you are
problem solvers and collaborators you
are innovators you are entrepreneurs
like Aaron like Jonathan like Randy you
are prepared to do great things to deal
with the most difficult situations to
live a life of meaning and purpose and
to make a difference in the world we
your University will be watching with
great pride once again great
congratulations and all the best to all
of you
you